eli where does a great story begin for
you boy I don't know a hard question to
start with
where does it begin do you mean
something that I'm writing or something
that I'm experiencing something that I'm
watching could be both you could maybe
think of a movie that really you know
sort of drew you into your love for film
yeah I mean I guess it's not necessarily
this it's not necessarily the story that
engages me it's more the point of view I
think point of view is the most
important thing because I think that we
tell a lot of the same stories but it is
it is the way that they are told the way
that they are executed that makes them
interesting and makes them unique and I
think that's the thing that I respond to
and that's the thing that I'm most
conscious of is what is my point of view
and trying to tell a story what am I
trying to get at that's different then
someone else's approach to the story so
it's that it's the their view of the
world and that point of view can be
political it can be apolitical it can be
philosophical a it's it's the uniqueness
of the of the perspective of the person
telling the story that I think is the
most critical yeah like if you think
about a reality TV and the dating shows
and then you take something like
Sherman's march okay I know that's going
back a few years but well it's a great
film it's excellent and just seeing the
guys I was it's Ross it was really okay
his is like hesitancy and his falling in
love and then falling in love with
someone new and then being in this small
town and all the expectations with that
and then you could see the exact same
thing and we'll leave the name of the
show's out but something about the way
that Ross did it was so natural I could
have watched another three hours of it
yeah I mean the way he's old he is not
afraid to let
his intention devolve and I mean I even
wouldn't even have to talk about a
different subject matter you could
certainly I'm sure there have been
multiple films or television shows that
have been made about Sherman's march
that are just a kind of straight well we
might call expository retelling of the
history right and so those may have
value or may not have value but I think
what makes that film sort of so memoral
the memorable is because that approach
he's not afraid to let this that's gonna
be about oh I meant this other girl
today you know and also he lets one
scene is from that and it's really
interesting I haven't thought about that
film in a long time wouldn't you bring
it one scene when I think of that film
that stands out is there's two women in
the kitchen talking about you know we
talking about the Civil War and they
lost but when that war had when it comes
again we're gonna be ready for it this
time or something like that and so he's
he's still delving into the history he's
still delving into the sort of cultural
wounds that are there that are present
but also telling this great really funny
really unexpected that's that's
absolutely a great example of a kind of
uniqueness of point of view that you
would not expect when you're watching a
movie that's supposedly about Sherman's
march why it's three hours long yeah
you're like I could take another three
hours and this is so good yeah yeah no
he's great he's really interesting he's
an interesting guy he's a fun guy to
listen to yeah I started what expository
can you mean to say so expository is
like Bill Nichols is this he's actually
a former professor of mine he was up at
San Francisco State and he was at one
time considered one of the foremost
authorities maybe still is I don't know
on documentary film and so he broke down
what he called the modes of documentary
film and the different their different
approaches
trying to find the their notion of truth
and one of them is what's called
expository and expository mode so an
expository mode is a mode that believes
in a kind of absolute truth and tries to
just relay facts to the audience member
so that those facts might come through
title cards that give us factual
information it might come through in a
sort of authoritative voice over where
someone is giving you this is when this
happened this is what this is going on
but it is a it's a treatment of the
documentary world in this notion of
truth as absolute and the film's job is
to deliver those truths through those
facts to you via different techniques
we're talking head interviews for
instance you get an expert to come in
and say this is what happened this is
why it happened all that sort of stuff
and so you could absolutely see a film a
documentary about Sherman's mum servants
march that takes that kind of tact where
here's a historian historians gonna talk
about it and we'll give you some
voiceover and we'll give you some title
cards that'll give you the facts of when
this happened and when that happen
whereas McKelvey it's much more
subjective it might even be called what
we what Nichols calls performative where
it's all about the personal it's all
about the subjective so yeah that's
that's again I think that's what makes
that it's so interesting was that some
of what was done with sixty minutes I
know I'm dating myself with that one but
I can remember there's a style yeah yeah
absolutely yeah you know or if you I
mean if you look at if you look at sort
of documentaries especially from the 40s
and 50s that's the stuff that kind of
dominated that kind of expository style
or even something like march of the
Penguins like is to use somewhat more
contemporary example you know that there
is we're gonna teach you facts here's
facts about penguins and here's facts
about how penguins mate and their whole
cycle what they do throughout the year
and we're gonna use Morgan Freeman's
voice to give you that information and
that way there's something about
selecting Morgan Freeman knowing that
the audience is going to trust him right
he's going to deliver this factual
information and the audience will take
it as facts as the truth you know that's
a very exposed Tori style which is way
different than like the film I mentioned
before turn on the camera stories we
tell Sara Polly's movie which is a
really really interesting use of the
kind of performative style where she
does these reenactments but you don't
know that they're reenactments when
you're watching them and she's she's
very much throughout the course of the
film questioning the notion of what the
truth is he or she's trying to retell
the story of how her family essentially
and there's also an extreme danger with
that because you could think back to
like propaganda films yeah of the 40s
and 30s and things like that yeah well I
mean like you get into you Duty you get
into question notions of what is the
truth
but this here you get into ethical sort
of dilemma of what your role is as a
documentary filmmaker and what what you
oh I guess what you're supposed to try
to achieve some would say in this kind
of 6 60 Minutes style that we're trying
to to delve into this kind of the
absolute truth and trying to figure that
out whereas others might say that
there's no way to do that it's
impossible there's no way to sort of
remove yourself
one of the ways i if I'm lecturing on
documentary film one of the things that
I will talk about is how it's impossible
to remove bias there's no such thing as
sort of an unmediated film meaning you
or a documentary film you can't remove
your own perspective no matter how hard
you try the example I'll give is you
know if I if I decide that I'm going to
make a film about Long Beach City
College students right that's what I've
decided I'm gonna do and there's like
thirty thousand students that attend
this school there's no way I can talk to
all thirty thousand students so I'm just
going to talk to this
class of 80 kids baby students but even
talking to 80 students is too difficult
so I'm just gonna take the first two
rows which is like 15 students and I'm
going to talk to those 15 students and
when I'm doing those those interviews I
discover that this student over here is
not interesting on camera at all they're
boring so I can't use them I've got to
cut them out but this student over here
is really interesting so she's gonna be
all over my movie because I think she's
saying all kinds of interesting things
and it aligns with what I think is is
possibly the proper perspective about
being a long beach city college student
so that I posed this question to them
where's the first time I showed my bias
by choosing the one interesting student
long before that I showed my bias when I
decided to make a movie about Long Beach
City College students as soon as I just
made that choice as soon as I said that
I'm gonna make a film about Long Beach
City College students I decided not to
make a film about Donald Trump the
automobile cats whatever like there's a
perspective right there I'm saying that
this is interesting this is newsworthy
this should be a film I have just
indicated a bias right there
and so there's no way to separate your
point of view or your perspective or
your way of seeing the world once
because you're making choices
immediately when I just decide to pick
up the camera and shoot something I've
made a choice so I I always think that
those films of film like stories we tell
a film like Sherman's march um the stuff
that Verna Hertzog doesn't like grizzly
man those films tend to be for me or
Errol Morris's documentary work tend to
be the most interesting because they're
the ones that are acknowledging that
this truth is out here and it's elusive
and I don't know if it actually exists
and we can grab it or not all I can do
is present my point of view and this is
all very slippery
I don't know that feels that feels more
honest to me then here's the truth we're
gonna give you the truth of the
expository style I mean there's all
kinds of people who do stuff with with
observational documentary like someone
like Frederick
it's just masterful of the Maysles
brothers before they died we're great at
that stuff
you